matthew asks is it better to update your  social networks once a week with great  content or daily the poor content  Matthew why does it have to be one or  the other why not both I am so tired  that people think that this is kind of  like the thing that pisses me off the  most Oh Gary I see you hustle so much  but I don't work hard I work smart well  hey [ __ ] I work both I work  ridiculously hard and I work obnoxiously  smart and that is my answer to this  question why not just put out a lot of  content often that is quality why does  one have to suffer or the other that is  a mistake mentality that is a middle  mindset go all in you can do both I do